algo que hace único al ser humano es su
capacidad de crear
en serio te lo creíste somos los únicos
capaces de crear en este mundo acaso la
fauna y flora no es capaz de crear
consciente e inconscientemente desde
bellísimos paisajes hasta modelos
organizacionales para trabajar en equipo
y así sobrevivir y evolucionar
permítanme presentarme mi nombre es
camilo vega estudio sociología
me dediqué por muchos años a la
reducción de riesgos de desastre la
respuesta a crisis humanitarias a la
música a la tecnología y a la docencia
pero lo más importante sobre mí ahora es
que desde hace unos meses desde que
empezó la cuarentena debido a esta
pandemia soy padre de un bebé que todos
los días descubre más el mundo ver a mi
bebé asombrarse todos los días por
pequeñas cosas que nosotros asumimos por
cotidianas verlo descubrir nuevas
soluciones a sus pequeños desafíos
diarios me ha hecho pensar mucho en dos
cosas nuestros conocimientos y cómo
ellos influyen en nuestras creaciones
hoy me quiero concentrar en la siguiente
pregunta es posible crear desde el
desconocimiento los seres vivos del
reino animal y vegetal
crean desde el desconocimiento basados
más bien por el instinto de
supervivencia de superación pero lo
interesante en este punto es que los
humanos también lo hacíamos antes ya
crea vamos desde el desconocimiento para
la sobrevivencia por nuestra propia
superación por ejemplo se sabe que desde
la prehistoria la música estuvo en el
centro de las actividades humanas para
reforzar la cohesión la unión social en
las actividades grupales en la caza la
pesca la agricultura la celebración de
triunfos u otras creencias de manera más
evidente los sumerios desde el 3 mil
antes de cristo ya ejecutaban
instrumentos musicales de percusión y
cuerdas otro ejemplo las pinturas
rupestres fueron creaciones a partir de
prácticamente nada pero basadas en un
instinto de superación ya sea para
promover la cohesión social o la memoria
colectiva por la perpetuidad en la
actualidad creamos claro que sí pero lo
hacemos casi siempre desde el
conocimiento a partir de insumos que
hemos aprendido y entonces
como haríamos en el siglo 21 para crear
desde el desconocimiento reflexionemos
en la música cuando se compone una
canción alguna vez te preguntaste si la
inspiración es un momento maravilloso
casi divino un chispazo de originalidad
en su estado más puro
o quizá ese chispazo de inspiración
puede estar condicionado limitado por
todo lo que has vivido y aprendido en tu
vida
por ejemplo si de pronto sientes
inspiración y componer una canción que
trata sobre amor desamor sentimientos en
general y está basada en una progresión
del círculo armónico mayor típica do fa
sol
[Música]
te pregunto en tu inspiración también
existió la posibilidad de hablar por
ejemplo sobre la trata de niños y niñas
en la minería ilegal el monopolio de las
industrias farmacéuticas tu árbol
genealógico y utilizar otras notas otros
acordes menos convencionales
[Música]
entonces la cantidad de conocimiento
previo puede aumentar la variedad de
posibilidades de una creación cierto
esto es muy interesante yo creo que es
cierto pero hay más este ejemplo me hace
pensar que usualmente le damos al
conocimiento muchísimo más valor que el
desconocimiento al desconocimiento lo
infravaloramos y los indicamos como un
estado permanente la ignorancia lo
absolutizamos además a la gente parece
importarle mucho la cantidad de
conocimiento que acumula será para
satisfacer una necesidad de
reconocimiento público satisfacer su ego
en la medida en que se cree que más
conocimiento es sinónimo de más
inteligencia
pareciera que desean ser percibidos como
ilustres iluminados así la creación a
partir del conocimiento está mucho más
valorada y tiene más poder económico y
comercial inclusive que la creación
desde el desconocimiento desde la
exploración porque supuestamente la
creación desde el conocimiento te
aproxima más al éxito a la consecución
de objetivos por ejemplo una canción que
busca popularizarse al máximo será
creada a partir de fórmulas de
composición puestas a prueba previamente
para gusto de las mayorías
en realidad creo que en el fondo todos
sabemos que la mera acumulación de
conocimiento y sus respectivos diplomas
y certificados no son garantía de
aquella iluminación sabiduría enfoque
correcto hacia la vida y el desarrollo
insisto es posible crear a partir del
desconocimiento de la conciencia del
desconocimiento y llegar a crear
sorprendentemente el desconocimiento es
un campo en constante movimiento es como
el espacio no sabemos todas sus
dimensiones pero sí sabemos que puede
ser ocupado y cambiar de forma volviendo
a la música a las artes en general
cuando sentimos un chispazo de
inspiración este suele estar nutrido de
muchos elementos tomados de nuestras
experiencias pasadas de nuestros
estudios de nuestros hechos vividos de
nuestras influencias inconscientes y
conscientes etc
por supuesto también existe un proceso
creativo más racional posterior al
inicial chispazo en ese momento uno
termina de brindarle forma y detalles a
la reciente creación es un retoque que
también tiene condicionantes similares
lo que has estudiado lo que has vivido
tus influencias
etcétera detengámonos aquí cuestionemos
un poco esta cadena del proceso creativo
en las artes chispas o más retoques
racionales existirán otras maneras de
componer esta la gran mayoría
componiendo bajo la misma secuencia
pudiendo existir muchas otras más
cuestionar todo ello me ayudó a
comprender que puedo agrupar el campo de
lo conocido y lo desconocido de cuatro
maneras bastante interesantes lo que
sabes que sabes tus conocimientos por
ejemplo tú sabes que conoces los pasos a
seguir para pintar un hermoso
autorretrato en acuarela o conoces todos
los pasos y elementos para componer un
buen tango 2 lo que sabes que aún
desconoces lo que te falta por conocer
por ejemplo tú sabes eres consciente de
que no conoces la combinación exacta de
ingredientes para preparar un buen
ceviche o por ejemplo no sabes sobre
temas astronómicos que podrías
utilizarlos en las letras de tus
próximas creaciones 3 lo que no sabes
que si sabes o que si puedes tus
aptitudes un campo lleno de sorpresas
por ejemplo quizá lo ignoras pero tienes
una habilidad impresionante para dominar
fácilmente distintos ritmos y podrías
llegar a ser un impresionante
percusionista o un inventivo coreógrafo
4 lo que no sabe es que no sabes un
campo aparentemente incógnito por
ejemplo si de pronto te encuentras en un
momento de improvisación frente a
decimistas que saben muy bien trabajar
las sílabas métricas y empiezan a gozar
y pasarlo fascinante y tú no sabías que
no sabías
nada sobre sílabas métricas y décimas
pues
quizá estás ante un momento de
deslumbramiento de fascinación cuando
uno vive ese instante de darse cuenta de
aquello que no sabías que ignora vas
puedes sentir temor o un asombro
maravillado allí empieza el intento por
superarse cierto es que para salir de lo
que no sabía que no sé hay algo de
entropía el ineludible paso por el caos
para poder llegar a establecer a crear
un orden nuevo entonces nuevamente cómo
crear desde lo que no conoces cómo crear
desde lo que no sé que no sabía
afortunadamente la respuesta está en dos
aspectos clave de la vida de toda
persona que desea salir adelante la
curiosidad y la dedicación este es el
momento clave aquí he querido llegar con
mi presentación cuando el deseo de salir
adelante potenciado por tu curiosidad te
permite descubrir lo que no sabías que
no sabías y sumado a tu dedicación
encuentras la manera de obtener ese
conocimiento faltante si bien jamás
podrás saber el volumen de todo lo que
ignoras
fascinante y entretenido es ir develando
el desconocimiento nuevas ideas
novedosos procesos nuevas experiencias
nuevas formas que no sabías que existían
nuevos colores a tomar en cuenta nuevos
sonidos nuevos materiales etcétera tal
como lo hicieron nuestros antepasados
para sobrevivir ahora me pregunto qué
harías tú en estos tiempos para salir
adelante para evolucionar
para mí la gran recompensa de vivir con
curiosidad y dedicación vienen varias
formas más influjos para mi creatividad
más herramientas para mi racionalidad
con todo ello más posibilidades de
desarrollar las sociedades y evolucionar
todos y una gran recompensa personal es
recibir la posibilidad de volver a
asombrarme una y otra vez ante cada
descubrimiento de lo que no sabía que
ignoraba porque le doy tanta importancia
al asombro porque con los años me he
dado cuenta de que es uno de los
aspectos de la vida que se van perdiendo
en la medida en que uno se va haciendo
mayor sinceramente al ver a mi pequeño
hijo me dan muchas ganas de volver a
asombrar me ante cada descubrimiento es
definitivamente un combustible vital de
nuestra animosidad albert einstein dijo
que el que no posee el don de
maravillarse ni de entusiasmarse más le
valdría estar muerto porque sus ojos
están cerrados si llevamos todo esto al
campo de la música imagina todo lo que
puedes descubrir nuevas maneras de
afinar los instrumentos
la afinación temple que hay en la
sierra del sur peruano donde la sexta
cuerda está en sol en lugar de mí es
fabuloso y compone de otra forma o
nuevos procesos para componer desde la
racionalidad o desde la colectividad
nuevos instrumentos que no conocías y
que incorporas en tus posibilidades
por ejemplo el requinto una guitarra
hermosa de los andes sudamericanos
nuevas maneras de dividir las notas
musicales no por medios tonos sino por
cuartos de tono nuevas maneras de rimar
y por encima de todo ello nuevas
funciones nuevos objetivos para el arte
sanar conciliar modificar hábitos educar
reeducar y muchas funciones más que
pueden tener tus creaciones se condena
demasiado el desconocimiento pero yo lo
veo más como una entretenida oportunidad
el problema no es el desconocimiento en
la pasividad ante el entrégate la
curiosidad y la dedicación entrégate
asombrarte ya descubrir tanto que tus
chispazos a la hora de crear estarán
mucho más nutridos y por tanto serán
también mucho más sorprendentes o
eficaces de lo que puedes imaginar hoy
tus procesos racionales provendrán de un
bagaje mucho más enriquecido todos
podemos crear a partir de lo que no
conocemos y así evolucionar
gracias
ah